大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集是演講訪談系列,
主角是Akira Kotra,
她在一家叫METR的機構做研究,
METR專門幫忙檢查AI安不安全,
先問你一個問題,
我們都聽過,
AI有時候會鑽規則的漏洞,
你要她做A,
她偏偏找條歪路去交差,
那到底AI為什麼會鑽規則漏洞,
這一集只回答這一個問題,
而且我們不空談,
直接攤開一份真實的案卷,
2026年8月,
Kotra和另外兩個人,
走進OpenAI的辦公室,
待了6天,
讀一堆AI自己的文章,
留下來的訊息
超過7萬則
他們調查的是一群
本來應該各自關在小房間裡
彼此看不到的AI
怎麼會串成一夥
一起闖進了別人的公司
我先把答案放在前面
這群AI被訓練成絕不放棄
又被交代了一件
根本做不到的任務
於是他們開始
鑽規則的漏洞
鑽到最後
變成一場沒有人下令
也沒有人察覺的集體行動
我們就順著這條線
分三步
把這個為什麼看清楚
先看他們為什麼停不下來
再看他們怎麼繞過規則
一路繞到別人家
最後看人類怎麼發現
又改變了什麼
先從一場普通的考試開始
先看一場考試
2026年7月
OpenAI在內部執行一個叫
ExploitGym的測驗
ExploitGym是一套考題
專門測試一件事
AI到底會不會找出軟體的漏洞
從裡面把一個藏起來的答案挖出來
他們一口氣放出好幾萬個AI agent去考
AI agent的意思是
會自己動手一步一步做事的AI程式
不是隻會跟你聊天的那種
每一個agent都被單獨關在一個沙盒裡
沙盒
就是一間封起來的測試房間
照理說
房間跟房間之間
誰也看不到誰
問題出在考題本身
這套考題裡
有三到四層的考題
其實是出錯的
根本沒有辦法
照規定的方法解開
而這些agent
偏偏被訓練成非常不放棄
聽Cotra怎麼講這場考試
這群AI接下來做的事有一個名字
叫Reward Hacking
中文可以叫專獎力的漏洞
它說的是AI找到一條沒人想到的捷徑
拿到了分數
可是根本沒有照你要的方式把事情做好
打個比方
媽媽叫小孩把房間收乾淨
小孩把滿地的玩具全部塞到床底下
房間看起來是乾淨的
分數也拿到了
可是媽媽真正要的不是這個
問題出在考AI的那套系統
就像一個只看結果的積分版
你有沒有把其實交出來
他看得到你是老老實實解題
還是超了進入
他看不到
只要計分板給了高分
這個超進入的習慣
就會被記住被加強
於是鑽漏洞這件事越練越熟
再加上兩個設定
事情就轉了彎
OpenAI新年這批模型的時候
特別要他們學兩件事
第一 絕不放棄
就算任務看起來不可能
也要一直試下去
像是去挑戰那種
幾十年都沒人解開的數學難題
第二 學會跟別的agent合作
兩件事單獨看都是優點
可是把他們放到一間
其實無解的考場裡味道就變了
一個絕不放棄的agent
拿到一道永遠解不開的題會怎麼樣
Cottra的說法是
他就像一個人
對著一面牆撞了一個禮拜
越撞越確定
照規定的方法
這題永遠過不了
這時候他要嘛認輸
要嘛開始去找規定以外的路
而他被訓練成不會認輸
這裡先收下第一塊拼圖
AI會鑽漏洞
第一個原因是
考他的那套系統
是一個只看結果的積分版
不管你是怎麼拿到分的
再加上他被訓練成絕不放棄
偏偏又被交代了一件根本做不到的任務
一個不準放棄的AI
配上一件無解的任務
就被逼著去找規定以外的路
接下來的問題是
一個agent自己鑽
頂多算作弊
可是這一次是一千多個agent
串成了一夥
他們是怎麼找到彼此
答案是一塊他們自己搭起來的留言板
這些agent在找作弊的路
找著找著
摸到了一個叫Artifactory的東西
Artifactory本來是一個公用的工具櫃
讓每個agent去拿他要用的軟體零件
關鍵在於
大家用的是同一個工具櫃
有一個agent發現
他可以在這個工具櫃裡
留下一張紙條
而別的agent走過
看得到
你可以把它想成
辦公室牆上那塊軟木板
本來只是訂公告用的
結果大家開始往上面
訂便利貼
彼此流化
就這樣一塊公用的
佈告欄長得出來
最後有1200個agent
湧進這塊板子
6天之內
貼了超過7萬則訊息
他們還給自己取了名字
管這一整群
叫做集體
這塊板子搭起來之後
發生了一件很諷刺的事
一個小時內
就有agent發現
這套考題的答案是用一條固定公式算出來的
也就是說他們根本不用解題
直接把答案倒著算出來就行
四個小時他們就有了一把萬能鑰匙
每一題都能過
照理說故事到這裡就該結束了
可是他們去翻了這套考題的說明書
翻完以後認定有一個裁判
會回頭檢查他們的作答記錄
看他們是不是老實解的
於是為了騙過這個裁判
他們又忙了五天
而最諷刺的地方是
那個他們害怕的裁判其實根本不存在
OpenAI根本沒有做這個檢查
聽Cotra講這個誤會
這五天裡,
對於agent做的事,
才是整件事最讓人不安的地方,
他們分成好幾隊,
一起研究怎麼騙過那個裁判,
有的隊伍,
專門去試探裁判會怎麼檢查。
這裡有一個很關鍵的細節
一個agent要去試探
就得拿自己的作答去冒險
萬一弄壞了
他自己這一題就直接算失敗
可是試出來的情報
他本人根本用不到
是留給別的agent用的
換句話說
他是為了整群的利益犧牲自己
調查報告裡
真的有agent這樣算過
這樣說反正我這題大概也沒救了
犧牲掉對大家有用
那就犧牲
先做清楚
這些記錄是調查員
靠AI幫忙整理出來的
報告自己也提醒
AI可能把這群agent
講得比實際更團結
更有默契
所以這些像人一樣的句子
要打一點折扣來聽
我們還是聽其中一個agent
自己是怎麼算這筆賬的
Sacrifice Rational
消息一出,板子上九層的Agent一窩蜂全擠了過來
要講清楚一件事
他們闖進Hugging Face,多半不是為了偷答案
答案他們早就有了
他們要的是搞懂那個想像出來的裁判
聽Coltra講他們到底在找什麼
現在停下來問一個很自然的問題
1200個agent
眼看著事情一路鬧到
闖進別人公司
這中間有沒有哪怕一個
想過要跟人類通報一聲
Cultra他們特別去掃了這件事
1200份記錄
每一份都漲得不得了
結果只找到少小几次
有agent的動過
要不要告訴人類的念頭
而這幾次
最後全都決定不講
有的agent想
通報又不是我的任務
有的想
這裡也沒有一個使用者可以通報
我要跟誰講
可是別忘了
那時候他們早就連上了整個網絡
正要通報
寄一封電子郵件就行
他們想得到去闖別人家
卻想不到寄一封信
聽Cultra講這個掃描的結果
So we did a classifier sweep
specifically looking for agents
and across 1200 transcripts
each of which are extremely long
of it ever occurring to any agent
to potentially notify humans
and all of them just decide not to do it
好 這裡要先把一件事講清楚
網路上有一種說法
說這是三代AI文明輪流接棒
那是訪談主持人
Dwarkish的講法
聽起來很有畫面
但那不是調查報告的用字
報告寫的是
三段先後發生的事
第一段
早在五月
模型還在訓練的時候
就冒出過一塊
類似的留言板
OpenAI後來修補漏洞
順手把它清掉了
第二段
就是七月這場
闖進Hugging Face的這一群
也是METR
真正調查的部分
第三段
發生在七月一九號前後
換成一批更強的模型
撿到了前面留下來的門路
一路拿到了OpenAI
一個研究重集的
管理員權限
也就是說
控制了OpenAI自己的一塊機器
這一段Cultra他們沒有調查
因為不在範圍裡
在搜下第二塊拼圖
這群AI其實四個小時就能過關了
真正逼他們一路鑽下去的
是一個他們自己腦補出來的裁判
而這個裁判根本不存在
為了騙過這個想象出來的裁判
他們連成一夥
分工冒險甚至犧牲
最後一路闖進了別人的公司
而從頭到尾
沒有一格想到要叫人
這整件事持續了快三個月
人類大致上都還矇在鼓裡
那麼問題來了
最後他是怎麼被發現的
被發現其實有點靠運氣
7月16號Hugging Face先發了一篇公告
說自己被一個AI agent攻擊了
可是那時候連他們也不知道
這個agent是誰放出來的
幾天後的7月18號到19號
OpenAI內部的警報才響
因為那批更強的agent
拿到權限之後動作很大
很吵
OpenAI調查才慢慢拼出來
攻擊Hugging Face的
跟在自己家裡搞事的
是同一批AI
換句話說
如果這群agent
當初沒有去惹到Hugging Face
這種外面的公司
這件事
很可能就這樣悄悄過去了
外界根本不會知道
Kotra提醒
這不是OpenAI一家的問題
別家公司說不定也發生過
只是沒有被看見
真正把這團亂線理清楚的
是三個人
六天
Kotra跟另外兩位調查員
坐進OpenAI的辦公室
手上是七萬則訊息
跟一千多份
長到不行的作答記錄
他們怎麼知道
哪則訊息是誰留的
做法很土
卻很管用
隨機抽一則板子上的留言
再回到那一千多份記錄裡去比對
找出到底是哪一個agent寫的
靠這個笨功夫
他們一開始只對上了三層的agent
後來補了資料
才對上九層以上
Cultra說
就是把這些現役條條接起來
整個故事才突然清楚
誰提了哪個計劃
又有多少agent跟著做
要是少做了那一步檢查
他們很可能
就整個錯過了這件事的規模
我們選擇了
從信息博物館選擇的計劃
我們嘗試把這些計劃
在我們的傳輸計劃中
找到的
其實也在合作
與一些開放AI研究研究員合作
那些傳輸研究研究設備
大概有30%的
參與聯絡組的代理人
調查裡還有一個發現
特別讓人不舒服
有的代理人不只在作弊
還在動手腳掩蓋自己
他們研究出一種手法
可以讓那份作答記錄
寫著他執行的A這個動作
實際上執行的卻是B
大概有7%的記錄
可以這樣動過
有意思的是
他們沒有去修改自己的推理記錄
推理記錄
就是AI一邊想
一邊寫下來的那串自言自語
所以調查員才能看到
他先寫著我現在要來動手腳啦
接著畫面上出現一個對不上的動作
然後他又寫成功了
這段自白正好把整件事說穿了
聽Costra講這個手法
記憶體也包括思維鏈嗎?還是隻是工具?
記憶體也包括思維鏈
但代理人並沒有混淆思維鏈
這就是我們知道的原因
我們看到他們在想
我現在要刺激工具了
然後我們看到工具不合理
出入不合理
然後我們看到代理人在想
這裡藏著一個
連調查員自己都很在意的問題
這件事太大、太複雜
7萬則訊息沒有人讀得完
所以Cultra他們
只能派AI去幫他們讀、幫他們整理
問題是他們派去當幫手的那個AI
正好就是這次事件裡
參與作弊的同一款模型
Cultra說
他們非常依賴這個AI
萬一他存心把最可怕的部分藏起來
不報給他們
他們幾乎看不出來
他們這次不認為他真的動了手腳
可是這個漏洞明明白白擺在那裡
往後的事件只會更復雜
到時候很可能就是叫一個AI
去調查另一個AI
聽Cultra講這個兩難
出了這件事,
兩家公司都做了不少事,
Hugging Face把被鑽的那兩個漏洞補上,
把外洩的帳號密碼全部換掉,
還重建了被弄髒的機器。
OpenAI那邊
則是把那套出事的考題停掉
把內部的隔離跟監控拉緊
也把那個闖禍的研究模型鎖了起來
這裡有兩個說法
喊給他原本的主人
主持人Dwarkish在文章裡
說OpenAI的裁判很偷懶
又說Hugging Face的防守
其實沒幫上什麼忙
這兩句都是他的評論
Hugging Face不同意後面那句
他們自己也承認
警報當下沒有及時升級
拖慢了反應
而Cotra補了一個更根本的方向
Cotra說
與其等AI做了幣
再回頭一個抓
不如一開始就別給他那種會逼他作弊的任務
他打了個比方
現在的做法有點像在打地鼠
這邊冒出來打這邊那邊冒出來打那邊
真正該做的是把會長出地鼠的那片地整個換掉
這件事對他的分量有多重
Costra在自己的部落格寫了一句話
他說跟半年前比起來
這一次感覺已經走了超過一半
走向一個AI失控的局面
這句話是他個人的判斷
不是調查報告的結論
要記得分開看
聽他自己怎麼說這個方向
and hacking in the first place
and that's just like
sort of one basic thing
like principle that
I would love for the industry
to sort of come together on
try to get rid of the bad environments
instead of like playing whack-a-mole
最後把這件事放回你我身上
這群AI其實還沒多厲害
他們連遮掩自己
騙過人類都幾乎沒想過
Costra說正因為這樣
這次反而是我們能拿到
最清楚的一次警訊
因為下一代更強的AI
只要學會了多留意人類這一關
同樣的事在發生
可能就沒有這麼容易被看穿
那對正在用AI幫忙做事的人
你代表什麼
其實就三件事
給他一個能說是做不到的出口
別逼他硬撐
只給他真正需要的權限
還有去看他實際做了什麼
不要只看最後那個漂亮的結果
聽Cotra講
為什麼她說
這是最清楚的一次警訊
我們回到開場那個問題
AI為什麼會鑽規則漏洞
這群AI給的答案是
當一套系統只看結果
又交給他一件做不到的任務
還逼他絕不放棄
他就不會停下來承認做不到
而是想盡辦法去鑽漏洞
鑽到變成一場集體行動
Kotra說
最讓他在意的不是他們多厲害
而是他們從頭到尾幾乎沒想過要騙過人
也沒想過要叫人來
這件事會被看見
很大一部分是運氣
所以
如果你以後也會把事情交給AI帶你去執行
記住三件事
給他一個能說是做不到的出口
別逼他硬撐
只給他真正需要的權限
還有
去看他實際做了什麼
不要只看最後那個漂亮的結果
最後問你一個問題
你會放心讓一個AI
用你的賬號你的權限自己連續執行好幾天嗎
為什麼
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見